[Applaudissements]
capucine annabi capsule avec à lui
pendant sa va capucines tiens ça va bien
ma chérie tu es en forme et avec le fils
de qui en ce moment
non t'as pas de chance et a influencé
j'ai pas tu sais pas j'étais content
d'être là et après sa première fois
enfin sa première fois que tu viens ici
comment me
maman m'a dit que c'était toi qui étais
là ouais et je suis j'ai dit mais je
connais la vie voire la peine mais moi
je me souviens plus je trouverais plus
moi c'est comment je m'appelle mois
michel drucker y la mini agathe qui est
avec nous mais à bientôt
il ya gâteau poids les fameuses comment
ça va agathe moins ça va tu es content
d'être là oui pas me lancer dans
quelques classes non sans quelques
classes ppbe cpb dans ces pays croît vif
et bi des dents mais tant qu'elle classe
vraiment cp seulement passer la sepnb et
au savon
et pan cpa et non cpi était énervé en
fait on pas quand on compare avec les
siens